one of the biggest mysteries in one
piece has just been revealed and the
shocking truth is directly connected to
shank says dark Family secret but also
to zebek Blackbeard GARP Roger the
celestial dragons and the mind-blowing
conclusion of the one piece Story the
origins of several mythical Zone devil
fruits the truth about Shanks and Roger
and even the secret identity of Luffy's
mother could all go back to God valy
so let's get into it you guys know how
this works if you enjoy our one piece
content you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
for that YouTube algorithm and if you
want to help us get that mythical Zone 2
million subscriber subscriber fruit here
on YouTube do me a big favor and
subscribe right now it's completely free
and it helps me out a lot finally this
video will contain One Piece manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned for years now we've
all been wondering what really happened
during the the infamous God Valley
incident where the legendary rocks
Pirates attacked the celestial dragons
and where the hero of the Marines Monkey
D GARP had to team up with the future
pirate king Goldie Roger in order to
stop Zeek and his overpowered crew but
even before that we've all been
wondering about the secret origins of
redhaired Shanks and how he ended up on
rogers's crew at such a young age in the
very first chapter of the story Shanks
famously told Luffy that he was too
young young to become a pirate and that
young children don't belong on a pirate
ship and yet as we later learned Shanks
had been part of Roger's crew since he
was only one year old and where did
Roger first meet Shanks he met baby
Shanks on God Valley all the dots
finally started to connect with the
release of film red a free volume
containing interesting information about
one piece was distributed to attendees
of film red screenings in Japan and this
volume revealed that 38 years ago Roger
found a 1-year-old Shanks inside a
treasure chest on God Valley up to this
point we knew very little about the God
Valley incident so this was just another
fascinating piece of a much larger
puzzle we knew that 44 years ago rockd
zebic formed an unbelievably stacked
crew on the pirate island of hosu This
Crew included a young Whitebeard kaido
big mom Shiki silver axe Wang G and
Captain John among others now Rox wasn't
just interested in being a notorious
pirate or even the pirate king he openly
declared war against the world
government and he vowed to become the
king of the world the Rocks Pirates
waged war against the world government
for 6 years and then 38 years ago rocks
and his crew attacked a mysterious
island called God Valley according to
sangoku multiple Celestial dragons and
their slaves were present on God Valley
at the time of the attack the world
government was so determined to rescue
these Celestial dragons and to defeat
the Rocks pirates that they threw
everything they had at the Pirates
including a powerful Marine Force led by
vice admiral GARP but that wasn't the
weird part the weird part was that the
world government actually teamed up with
some of their greatest enemies Goldie
Roger and the Roger pirates in order to
defeat the Rocks Pirates together
apparently GARP and Roger were the ones
who led the battle against rocks and
according to the information that soku
gave us in chapter
957 Roger and GARP won Rock was killed
and the Rocks Pirates were disbanded you
can imagine just how dangerous zebec and
the Rocks Pirates must have been because
even though the world government and
Roger absolutely hated each other they
still decided to work together they must
have really believed that if Zeek won
the outcome would have been extremely
bad for everyone this suggests that Zeek
came pretty close to winning and to
becoming king of the world now back to
Shanks he was just a one-year-old baby
at that time but he was in fact there on
God valley during the incident in film
red the Goro state that Shanks is
actually a member of the figer land
family at the time of this reveal we
didn't know too much about this family
but there were some things that we could
conclude based on what the Goro said the
figland family was clearly well known to
the Goro and they express concern about
the fact that UTA is shank's adoptive
daughter because being shank's daughter
also makes her a member of the figur
land family the fact that the Goro
themselves know this family and are
concerned about UTA being a member of
the family implies that the figur lands
are an extremely influential family of
celestial dragons if they weren't why
would people who are as powerful as the
Goro say be concerned about them this
speculation was finally confirmed in
chapter 1086 six with the introduction
of St figland Garling a powerful World
Noble who serves as the supreme
commander of the Gods Knights and a man
who is known as the champion of God
Valley the gods Knights are an elite
group of Royal Guards who act as a sort
of police force in marijua they actually
rank above the Marines and unlike the
other world government forces they have
the authority to settle disputes between
Celestial dragons in fact their Supreme
Commander figer land ging has the
authority to actually carry out death
sentences against his fellow Celestial
dragons if you know anything about how
sacred the life of a Celestial Dragon is
and how entire kingdoms could be
destroyed just for hurting a single
Celestial Dragon then you know what a
big deal this actually is so we know
that Shanks is a member of one of the
most powerful families of celestial
dragons we know that both Shanks and
figland Garling were on God Valley
during the god Valley incident and we
know that for some reason after Roger
helped defeat the Rocks Pirates he found
baby Shanks inside a treasure chest and
made him a part of his crew but up to
that point we still didn't know what the
god Valley incident actually was we
didn't know why the celestial dragons
were there in the first place and we
didn't know how all of this connected to
the current storyline but then finally
in chapter 1,9 95 of the manga we got
our answers as the truth about the God
Valley incident started to be revealed
God Valley was an island in the West
Blue and 38 years ago it became the site
of a massive and grotesque tournament
organized by the celestial dragons this
type of event is organized every 3 years
and it always takes place at a different
location in this particular year they
chose God Valley an independent Kingdom
that was not affiliated with with the
world government part of the reason why
this kingdom was chosen was the fact
that its name was considered Blasphemous
by the celestial dragons even though the
name God Valley came from the fact that
the island had plenty of natural
resources meaning that it was blessed by
God the celestial dragons believe
themselves to be the true gods of this
world so some small unaffiliated island
referring to itself as God Valley was
unacceptable to them the world
government annexed the island and turned
it into the of their traditional human
hunt that's right every 3 years the
celestial dragons pick an island and
Hunt its native population for sport on
top of that they also throw in any
problematic slaves that have been giving
them trouble and they hunt the slaves as
well the tournament works on a point
system meaning that a participant will
get points based on how many humans they
successfully hunt down and then the
participant with the most points will be
crowned the champion of God Valley the
winner will also receive extremely rare
prizes as their reward and in the
flashback we see at least six treasure
chests being displayed as prizes that
can be won but we'll talk about the
prizes later because first we need to
talk about St figland Garling 38 years
ago figland Garling was a fairly young
man without a beard and ons surprisingly
back then he looked a lot like Shanks
Garling was one of the competitors at
the the god Valley tournament and he was
one of the Front Runners he was a fan
favorite among the celestial dragons and
it seemed that the female World Nobles
especially were very interested in him
even before the tournament started
Garling killed the king of God Valley
for expressing his opposition to the
tournament and this act of killing the
King before the tournament started
actually cost Garling 10,000 points
right off the bat but Garling wasn't
upset by this he said that he needs a
handicap in order to make things
interesting among the Troublesome slaves
who were to be hunted during the
tournament were a young Bartholomew Kuma
a young Emporio Ivanov and a young girl
named Jenny jinny's appearance in the
flashback was especially interesting
because it immediately sparked theories
about jinny's true identity if she is
there on God Valley with future members
of the revolutionaries like Ivan C and
Kuma then who would she eventually grow
up to be provided that she actually
survived the tournament could she be the
future mother of jewelry Bonnie or
crazier still could she be the future
mother of Monkey D Luffy after all in
the very first panel she shows up in she
is smiling broadly while eating a big
piece of meat those are definitely some
serious Luffy Vibes so yeah in just a
few brief panels so much important
information has been Finally Revealed
and if some of the fan theories are true
we might have just met Luffy's Mother
after
1,9 chapters of wondering who she might
be we now know what the god Valley
incident was and why so many Celestial
dragons were there in the first place
along with some of their slaves God
Valley was the location of a major world
Noble tournament where they hunted the
local population and some of their
slaves for sport the tournament operated
on a point system the competitor who
hunted down the most people was awarded
the most points and the winner was given
the title of champion of God Valley
along with some extremely rare and
valuable prizes prizes that were kept
inside those six treasure chests since
St figland Garling has been referred to
as the champion of God Valley in the
present time we can already conclude
that he ended up winning the tournament
that year but what we don't know yet is
how Zeek and The Rock Pirates became
involved in the god Valley incident and
how Goldie Roger ended up there and
fighting on the side of the world
government
since we know that the Rocks Pirates had
been active for 6 years prior to the god
Valley incident and since we know that
zeec declared war on the world
government and wanted to become the king
of the world we can conclude that he
learned about the location of the
tournament and he invaded the island
while the tournament was taking place or
just as it was ending his intention
might have been to eliminate all those
prominent Celestial dragons who came to
God Valley for the tournament which
would have been a massive blow against
his enemy the world government he may
have also intended to take some of them
hostage in order to extract concessions
from the world government lastly he
might have been after the prizes hidden
in those six treasure chests by the way
do those chests remind you of something
they look a lot like some of the devil
fruit chests that we've seen in the past
like for example the chest that carried
the NAA fruit what if these six chests
carried extremely rare and Powerful
devil fruits and maybe these fruits were
were meant to be handed out as prizes
for the winners of the tournament after
all we know that kaido's mythical Zone
devil fruit the uo noi model sadu had
actually been given to him by big mom
during the god Valley incident
apparently big mom gave him the devil
fruit in order to save his life but it
is certainly possible that she had just
stolen the devil fruit from the
celestial dragons during that very
incident we know that the Rocks Pirates
were all pretty individualistic and that
they were all looking out for their own
interests so if zebec told them to risk
their lives by attacking God Valley just
to help him become king of the world
they wouldn't have been too excited
about it but if he told them that if
they helped him they would be rewarded
with extremely rare and Powerful devil
fruits they would have been much more
likely to cooperate so yes I think that
kaido's devil fruit was almost certainly
stolen from the celestial dragons on God
Valley big Mom stole it and then she
gave it to kaido because he was in some
some kind of life-threatening danger and
the fruit was able to save him but if
that's only one of six treasure chests
then what about the other five did all
of them also contain extremely rare
devil fruits like maybe ivanov's fruit
and Kuma's fruit or did some of them
contain other things I don't think that
the celestial dragons would be stupid
enough to make Thea fruit one of the
rewards knowing how dangerous it could
be in the wrong hands but then again
they were so reckless about retrieving
it in the past so who knows that that
said it was many years later that Shanks
stole the naika fruit from a world
government ship so there's no evidence
that the naika fruit was actually on God
Valley well there is no evidence for now
but okay so we know that the celestial
dragons were having a horrible human
hunting tournament and that they were
offering valuable prizes including
probably rare mythical Zone devil fruits
and we know that zebec and the Rocks
Pirates crashed the party at some point
it makes sense for the world government
to call in all the reinforcements they
had available including vice admiral
GARP but where does Roger come in why
would Roger care about protecting the
world Nobles who are literally hunting
other human beings for sport even if the
Rocks Pirates were pretty bad it's hard
to believe that they could have possibly
been worse than the freaking Celestial
Dragon so again why would Roger risk his
own life and his own crew to team up
with the world government against the
Rocks Pirates honestly the thought of
Roger helping those horrible people
actually makes me kind of mad so I
really hope Oda will have a good
explanation this part about Roger is the
big missing piece of the puzzle and once
that part of the story is revealed then
we will surely learn how Shanks ended up
inside a treasure chest and how Roger
ended up taking him aboard his ship if
Shanks was a member of a prominent
family of celestial dragons then
presumably he would have been treated
extremely well by the other world Nobles
he would not have been abandoned on
purpose like a slave or something so
what happened since Garling is still
alive we know that Zeek didn't kill
Garling and steal Shanks from him this
brings us to the question is Garling
Shanks his father or just a member of
his extended family and if Garling is
his father then what happened to his
mother was she perhaps killed by the
Rocks Pirates and that's how Shanks
ended up inside that Treasure Chest like
maybe his mother hid him there from
rocks and then Roger found him now that
I think about it protecting innocent
children like Shanks may have been part
of the reason why Roger ended up siding
with the world government against zebic
eliminating the adult Celestial dragons
who take joy in hunting other humans is
one thing but eliminating literal babies
like Shanks is not something that Roger
would have been willing to accept so if
that was sebek's goal I can see why
Roger might get involved still if Shanks
is Garling son or even if he's a close
member of his family then then how has
he been able to operate as a yonko while
Garling continues to serve as the
supreme commander of the Gods Knights
have they really never confronted each
other in all the years since God Valley
and if they have are we going to get
that flashback because I would love to
see that we know how strong Shanks is
but is he strong enough to beat the
strongest World Noble after the gay
themselves the supreme commander of the
most elite fighting force that the world
government has ever prod produced I
think Shanks might have some trouble in
a one-on-one with Garling especially if
Garling really is his father and there
is a messy family drama aspect to the
fight what do you guys think about the
God Valley incident now that we know so
much more about it how did chanks end up
in a treasure chest and why did Roger
decide to take him in when members of
his family like Garling were clearly
still alive as a matter of fact why did
Roger decide to support the world
government in the first place when the
world nobl were literally hunting people
for sport on the island what was in the
other treasure chests and who is jinny
Bonnie's mother Luffy's mother let me
know what you think down in the comments
below if you're looking for an epic one
piece video to watch next check out our
video that explains all the awakened
devil fruits in one piece link on screen
and in the pin comment if you enjoyed
this one piece video and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like to
let me know and if you want to help us
eat that 2 million Sub sub fruit here on
YouTube do me a big favor and subscribe
right now